AWKWARD FAMILY PHOTOS.
YOU KNOW AWKWARD FAMILY PHOTOS.
OF COURSE, YOU DO. YOU'VE BEEN
ON THE INTERNET.
AN AMAZING LIBRARY OF PHOTO THESE
MISSED ARTIFICIAL JOY AND
CAPTURE PEOPLE'S INNER
WEIRDNESS.
THEY'RE SUCH HIGH ART THEY'RE
AMIDST A FOUR-MONTH-LONG MUSEUM
EXHIBITION.
COMEDIANS I WANT TO SHOW YOU
WHAT IS OFFICIALLY A PIECE OF
ART YOU AND BUZZ IN WITH A
CAPTION.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS BRAVE PLATOON
RIGHT OFF THE TOP.
YES!
>> TODD GLASS.
>> IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, JUST IN
CASE THEY WATCH THE SHOW, I WANT
TO BE NICE, SO MERRY CHRISTMAS
FROM THE DUMB ( BLEEP ).
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> NEXT ONE.
THESE FOUR FACIAL HAIR
AFICIONADOS.
>> COME ON, BOYS, PACK IN THERE
REAL TIGHT.
>> BROKE BENCH MOUNTAIN.
>> POINTS!
EXCELLENT!
>> OH, MAN, WHY DO I ALWAYS GOT
TO BE THE CABOOSE.
>> 5 GUYS BURGERS REGRETS TO
ANNOUNCE THE DEATH OF STEVE.
>> OH, NO!
THEY LOST THE FIFTH BROTHER.
POINTS.
NEXT ONE, THIS MOM JUST-- SHE'S
TRYING HER BEST, ALL RIGHT.
>> OH!
NOW I THINK IF YOU LOOK CLOSELY
YOU WILL SEE SHE'S IS COLLAPSING
HER VAGINA AS IF TO SAY, NO
MORE! NO MORE!
I AM DONE WITH IT! I AM DONE
WITH THIS.
NIKKI.
>> THINGS ARE JUST FINE WITHOUT
YOU, JIM.
( LAUGHTER )
>> POINTS!
>> WE'RE GOING TO BE OKAY!
WE'RE GOING TO BE JUST FINE!
>> EVERYTHING ABOUT THAT'S
GREAT.
AND, ALSO, GUYS, THEY'RE IN
SPACE, TOO, THEY'RE IN SPACE.
>> THIS IS FROM MY LEAST
FAVORITE EPISOAFD COSMOS.
I DIDN'T LIKE THAT ONE.
>> NEXT ONE, THIS IS A FAIRLY
NONTRADITIONAL FAMILY.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> IS THAT ONE MISSING AN EYE?
DON'T ( BLEEP ) WITH THAT GUY.
TODD.
>> AGAIN, I DON'T MEAN TO BE TOO
SENSITIVE.
I REALLY DON'T WANT TO MAKE FUN
OF THEM BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO BE
NICE PEOPLE IF THEY ADOPT A
BLACK PUPPET.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> NIKKI, DID YOU HAVE ONE.
>> FUN FACTS -- SHE'S HAD SEX
WITH EVERYONE IN THAT PICTURE
EXCEPT ONE.
>> POINTS, POINS!
>> POOR PAMELA. POOR,
POOR PAMELA.
>> THIS ONE'S GOING, "I HAVE THE
SOUL OF A REAL BOY."
>> ALL RIGHT, LAST ONE. A
COUPLE NUDISTS HERE.
LOOK AT THAT.
NIKKI.
>> SLOW NIGHT AT THE KEY PARTY.